Let's go next to our caller from the seven
eight six area code.
Who's on the phone today from seven eight
six and where are you calling from?
Hello.
Yeah, that's true.
Hi, I'm Steve from Miami.
Hey Steve.
What's going on?
Good.
I have two questions to the fact that Democrats
are really basically doing nothing.
And last election we had a huge turnout.
Don't you think it's going to backfire?
And these people who actually elected, I mean
voted for the first time, are going to be
so turned off that they're not going to vote.
Why?
Hold on.
People that voted when for the first time
and the last election,
2016 or 20 1818 okay.
People who turned, they voted for the first
time in 2018
yeah, huge amount of Democrats voted for the
first time.
Right.
In 2018
right.
And they might be turned off by what?
By the fact that the Democrats are really
not even going to impeachment hearings.
Okay.
So, so that's a very specific, so first you
said Democrats aren't doing anything.
Now you're saying they're not doing impeachment
hearings.
Yeah.
But there, that's basically nothing.
I mean,
well, hold on.
What does it, let's, let's get back to impeachment
in a second.
What is it Democrats in the house could have
done so far that they haven't done?
Well, the fact of the did impeachment hearings,
they would, you know, all these subpoenas
that are being rejected and all that.
Yeah, it'd be a different instance.
Okay.
And then the public, I mean, I don't know
if you watched a, what's a republican actually
said he should be impeached.
Justin
woman.
Okay.
There was a woman in there who was really
like, oh, the more report it said nothing
because she really didn't know at the end
of what, you know, she heard from him.
She was, her eyes were open and she's like,
oh, I didn't know that.
Because all she does listen to, you know,
the garbage on Fox and all that.
Oh.
[inaudible] if there were impeachment hearings
held, it would push out a lot of the facts
in the Mueller report to the general public.
I agree with you.
So let's take separately.
Should know that.
Yeah.
So I agree.
I'm thinking there, it's time for Democrats
in the house to start impeachment debate.
I agree with you completely.
Um, I don't think, now here's the thing, if
you believe that impeachment debate should
start, you probably want Trump to be president.
So I don't think that if Democrats don't hold
impeachment hearings, you're going to skip
voting for someone other than Trump in 2020.
I just don't think of
not.
But there may be a lot of people that will.
Okay.
I mean that this, so you're asserting that
I'm not, I've seen no evidence to suggest
that.
I think
did the margin he won by it was so slim?
Yes.
Okay.
So the fact that the, you know, the Democrats
has got a lot of new voters.
Okay.
Basically, I think I'm, I'm assuming, I'm
not going to say for sure.
It was basically they wanted Trump out was
an anti Trump vote
for a lot of people, it was.
Sure.
Right.
So they lose those people.
Cause I say, you know what, the Democrats
do nothing.
Okay.
So I'm not going to go with my vote's worth
nothing because I put somebody in power to
do something they do not like.
All right, well listen, I hope you're wrong.
You may be right.
Okay.
Specifically, but I will certainly look into
it more laid back.
So I'm gonna let you go.
Is the echo and waive my speaker phone or
some really seems
to have started.
Oh boy.
Okay, let's go to
our next caller from the two four zero area
code.
Something up with the phones today.